The vast environments of the video game ‘Monster
Hunter: World’ are home to incredible forms
of life — from thundering behemoths… to
ravenous hunters.
While the game focuses on battling monsters,
every creature on this continent has a life
of their own, with unique day-to-day patterns,
biological intricacies, and roles in the larger
ecosystems.
So, for this entry into the Archive, we’ll
show the life of this continent in entirely
new ways, and bring you closer to these creatures
than ever before.
And although doing fieldwork in this region
represents a significant risk, I’m determined
to document these extreme lifeforms firsthand.
So, let’s embark on this expedition together,
and discover what awaits in a land of giants…
On the southern shores of this enormous continent,
one of the first human settlements lies in
the shadow of the surrounding wilderness.
The village of Astera is walled off from the
dangers of the region’s interior, and will
serve as a useful base of operations for this
voyage.
I’m staying in an accommodation that my
host assures me is in no way a hastily converted
storage room.
The ceiling doesn’t seem… particularly
waterproof, but even in these humble lodgings,
I can smell the promise of discovery.
Or, perhaps that’s the smell of dirty laundry…
In either case, with the sun just beginning
to rise, I check my supplies one last time
and set off towards the wilderness beyond
the safety of Astera’s walls…
To the west, the most impressive forest on
the continent awaits.
This age-old environment is aptly called the
Ancient Forest, and it is a garden of wonders.
From sunlit clearings to dizzying heights,
each region of the Ancient Forest is an ecosystem
unto itself.
Beginning in a clearing along the shoreline,
I find a herd of slow-moving herbivores basking
in the early-morning sun.
These are Aptonoths, and despite their size,
they are among the gentlest species on the
continent.
They spend their days grazing on plentiful
vegetation and enjoying long sips of water
from the streams that flow through this region.
Indeed, I find Aptonoths are so mild mannered,
I can walk among them in safety.
Close observations reveal the Aptonoths live
in multi-family units, with infant Aptonoths
never straying too far from the watchful eye
of a parent.
For the Ancient Forest conceals many dangers.
And while Aptonoths have evolved an impressive
spiked club at the end of their tails for
defense, there are creatures in this environment
that might consider even the mightiest Aptonoth
nothing more than an appetizer.
To find such lifeforms, I’ll have to venture
deeper into the forest…
At the edge of the Ancient Forest, the vegetation
becomes thicker, and the branches cast long
shadows over the undergrowth.
And slinking among the foliage is a stealthy
social predator.
These are Jagras — nimble, reptilian lifeforms
whose mottled green and yellow coloration
helps them blend into their environment.
Relatively small by the standards of this
continent, a single Jagras couldn’t hold
their own against most of the creatures that
live here.
But like a wolf pack, the Jagras have solved
this problem by sticking together.
They travel together, hunt together, and when
one of them gets a kill… they eat together.
While they hunt in groups of two to three,
any spoils are split amongst all members of
the pack.
And with so many mouths, the meals rarely
last...
When all scraps have disappeared, the different
units silently split off once more, continuing
their persistent search for unwary prey…
And Jagras don’t just hunt on the forest
floor.
Their sinewy bodies are perfect for prowling
across the branches above.
In a forest whose branches form a network
of natural causeways, an attack can truly
come from anywhere.
I’ll have to stay on my guard as I venture
deeper into Jagras territory…
Peeking out from the underbrush, I glimpse
the entrance to a cave that the Jagras use
as a nest.
And from this opening, a titan emerges.
This is a Great Jagras.
A well-muscled, several-ton behemoth that
lumbers through the forest in search of food.
While I at first assumed the Great Jagras
to be a separate species from the smaller
Jagras, they’re actually a highly specialized
member of the pack.
Like a Silverback Gorilla, the Great Jagras
is bigger and heavier than the other group
members.
And they have to be, for the Great Jagras
don’t feed on small forest life like their
Jagras packmates.
They feed on Aptonoths.
Adult Aptonoths.
And to take down creatures as large as Aptonoths,
the Great Jagras will need to be quick and
decisive.
Once they catch the scent of their quarry,
the Great Jagras is off, charging with surprising
speed.
In an instant, the chase is over, and the
Great Jagras swallows their prey… whole.
This alarming display might seem truly monstrous,
but we can find similar behavior in various
Earth animals.
Crocodile jaws aren't wired to move sideways,
so they can’t chew, and must instead swallow
chunks of food whole.
The same is true for certain snakes, which
have evolved to gulp down prey larger than
their skulls thanks to a stretchy elastic
ligament in their lower jawbone.
We can assume the Great Jagras have converged
on a similar jaw structure.
Once a Great Jagras has swallowed their prey,
they need to make a quick exit.
With a full gullet weighing them down, they’re
vulnerable to predation, and move with caution.
But eventually, this Great Jagras drags their
way back to the safety of the nest.
Here, the Great Jagras heaves up a portion
of their meal and lets out a roar.
Dinner is served.
On cue, the other Jagras rush in and consume
the leftovers their larger packmate has left
them.
This extra nutrition will help the smaller
Jagras survive.
This dynamic is certainly a bit disgusting,
but far from unheard of in the animal kingdom.
Various types of birds bring food back for
their young in a similar manner.
And while the Great Jagras isn’t the parent
of the Jagras, they do assume a kind of parental
role within the pack — providing food and
protecting the nest against various outside
threats.
But there is one lifeform that can slip past
the Great Jagras unseen.
The Kulu-Ya-Ku is a bird-like species that
is remarkably crafty, and knows all the ins
and outs of the Ancient Forest.
And most notably, the Kulu-Ya-Ku has memorized
when the Great Jagras leave the nest to hunt,
which helps the Kulu-Ya-Ku score their favorite
food — Jagras eggs.
On Earth, many generalist predators consume
the eggs of ground-nesting birds to supplement
their diet.
But the Kulu-Ya-Ku isn’t stealing bird eggs,
but rather the eggs of a lifeform many times
their size.
So, this bird brain will need to be careful.
Sneaking into Jagras territory, the Kulu-Ya-Ku
pauses at the nest’s entrance.
They know that if they’re caught in the
act, they’ll be in serious trouble.
But fortune favors the bold.
Descending into the cave, their prize awaits.
Egg in hand, there’s no point in hesitating.
Running is now the best strategy.
The further they can get from the nest, the
better…
Safe at last.
Holding the egg in their long forelimbs, the
Kulu-Ya-Ku digs in.
This heist was successful, but the next one
might not be.
But the Kulu-Ya-Ku isn’t as helpless as
they might appear.
When threatened, the Kulu-Ya-Ku will pick
up a rock and use it to fend off other lifeforms.
I learned about this behavior when I followed
one too closely, and they tried to bash me
over the head.
Fortunately, the Kulu-Ya-Ku is rather cowardly,
and once I stood my ground, they turned away.
Tailing them more cautiously, I noticed the
Kulu-Ya-Ku will also use their flexible digits
to scratch in a very human-like manner, leaving
brilliant feathers on the forest floor.
The Kulu-Ya-Ku might be on the small side
for this environment, but with a keen intellect,
they’re able to eke out a life here…
Yet every environment needs an apex predator.
For the lower reaches of the Ancient Forest,
that predator is the Anjanath.
A huge, bipedal hunter, the Anjanath can feed
on just about anything that walks upon the
ground.
Even a Great Jagras is hopelessly outmatched
against the terror that is the Anjanath.
But the Anjanath didn’t reach the top just
by being the biggest.
To maintain their status within the lower
forest food web, this species has evolved
an array of unexpected adaptations.
The Anjanath’s nose, for example, is a strange
fleshy appendage on the tip of their snout
that expands when tracking prey, and greatly
enhances the creature’s sense of smell.
Like the nose of a bear, the Anjanath’s
snout contains hundreds of times more scent
receptors than a human’s.
It’s… an odd-looking sniffer, to be sure,
but a highly effective one.
For the Anjanath, having such a large nose
also means a frequent buildup of mucus, which
the Anjanath habitually sneezes out to mark
their territory.
It’s certainly a gross strategy — although
the pungent mixture does send an unmistakable
signal to others that this district is taken.
And this isn’t the only bewildering adaptation
of the Anjanath.
When charging into battle, the Anjanath extends
two massive sails from their back, which help
the Anjanath appear even larger.
And these sails have another function.
In a tropical climate like this one, a creature
as large as an Anjanath is in danger of overheating.
By extending these sails, the Anjanath can
radiate heat outwards while lying in the shade.
Certain lizards, like Igaunas, have similar
sails under their neck that help with thermoregulation.
The Anjanath might be formidable, but like
all creatures in the Ancient Forest, they
are more than just a monster…
Further to the north, the forest gives way
to a shimmering seascape.
Along this coast, a herd of Kestodon stretch
their legs.
Like the Aptonoths, the Kestodons are herbivores,
and have evolved numerous defenses to survive
in this ecosystem of teeth and claws.
Kestodon skulls possess an extremely thick
roof.
This allows them to charge potential threats,
without fear of injuring their skulls — a
behavior I observed first hand when I crept
too close.
From a safe distance, however, the Kestodon
herd appears remarkably peaceful.
Curiously, male Kestodon skull plates are
more extravagant, likely to aid in intra-species
combat.
Battles for dominance are a familiar sight
on Earth, with numerous types of animals competing
with other members of their own species — often
at the risk of their own life.
But based on my limited observations, Kestodon
herds seem more diplomatic.
In a biosphere of vicious competition, it’s
nice to see a species that’s a bit more
group-oriented.
Other species have less pleasant dispositions.
In the spore-filled region at the northeastern
edge of the forest, an ill-tempered omnivore
patrols their hunting path.
This brightly colored creature is a Pukei-Pukei,
and while they are only a medium sized organism,
they have a giant trick up their sleeve — or
rather, in their mouth.
The Pukei-Pukei’s tongue is nearly as long
as the creature themselves, and can be used
like a whip to stun other lifeforms.
The equally chromatic chameleons have a similar
tongue-to-body ratio, and like the Pukei-Pukei,
can lash out with their tongues with blazing
speed.
But the Pukei-Pukei is more than a one-trick
lifeform.
During one of my observation sessions, one
specimen launched a glob of a toxic compound
quite near my head.
As it turns out, the Pukei-Pukei is a highly
venomous species, thanks in part to their
unique diet.
The Pukei-Pukei feeds primarily on the toxic
seeds of the plants that flourish in this
region of the forest, and can turn their food
into a deadly mixture within their stomachs.
On Earth, Cinnabar Moths are known to ingest
poisonous plants and convert them into toxins
of their own within their own bodies.
The Pukei-Pukei don’t just spit liquid venom,
however, but can also release a foul gas cloud
that is deadly to breathe.
Despite this harrowing display of power, to
my surprise, the tiny terror soon retreats.
Further observations show that the Pukei-Pukei
is the bully of the Ancient Forest, terrorizing
smaller creatures but flying away in the face
of anything that seems threatening.
Not such a scary lifeform after all…
All sorts of smaller creatures inhabit the
thick and lush greenery of the lower forest,
living through their own daily dramas unbeknownst
to the tree-shaking titans this region is
known for.
Yet the role these tiny critters play in the
ecosystem shouldn’t be overlooked.
And while there are too many to name, one
in particular stands out.
The Mosswine.
These delightful creatures spend their days
sniffing out their favorite food, which in
the Mosswine’s case happens to be mushrooms.
At a glance, the snuffling Mosswine resembles
an Earth pig or wild boar, with the notable
addition of a bed of moss that seems to be
growing from the fur on their back.
This coating of moss forms as a result of
the Mosswines largely inactive lifestyle,
and helps them blend into the green of the
underbrush.
Various types of sloths can be seen with plant
matter growing on their fur for a similar
reason.
Yet unlike the sloth, the Mosswine’s role
in the ecosystem of the forest they inhabit
is absolutely critical.
According to my research, through their natural
routines, the Mosswine keeps the population
of fungus at a healthy level, affecting the
balance of the entire region…
Yet there is one lifeform so ravenous, they
can throw the entire forest out of balance.
This heavily-scarred colossus is a Deviljho,
and they are a stranger to the Ancient Forest.
The Deviljho is a nomadic hunter, known for
wandering vast distances in search of prey.
Their status as a super-predator allows them
to overtake the territory of organisms that
stand in their path.
As a result, the Deviljho wreaks havoc on
any ecosystem they invade.
On our own planet, invasive predators, like
Lionfish in the North Atlantic, pose a similar
threat.
Organisms adapted for one environment that
move to another — either by their own accord
or, in the Lionfish’s case, human negligence
— often find themselves in an ecosystem
with prey that have no defenses against their
specific hunting strategy.
And the Deviljo are no different.
Thankfully, however, the Deviljo seem to be
few in number.
Indeed, with so few Deviljo on this continent,
many seem unhealthy due to low genetic diversity.
Soon, the biosphere of the forest may be free
of their influence.
I’ve now explored the lower reaches of Ancient
Forest.
Yet there is a new world waiting in the branches
above, home to even more extreme forms of
life.
It’s a long and dizzying climb upwards.
Best not to look down…
While making the trek upwards, I cross paths
with a seldom-glimpsed wonder.
This enigmatic traverser of the treetops is
a Tobi-Kadachi.
A stealthy loner, the Tobi-Kadachi can move,
cat-like across the branches.
And the Tobi-Kadachi has a secret ability.
Periodically, the creature will brush up against
nearby objects.
As a result, vast amounts of static electricity
collect in the Tobi-Kadachi’s specialized
spines, which they can unleash upon any creature
that bothers them.
On Earth, honeybees are known to beat their
wings at such a fast rate that they generate
an electrical charge, which they use to help
them keep track of which flowers they’ve
pollinated.
Static electricity typically isn’t strong
enough to cause much damage, however, which
is why hunters like the Electric Catfish generate
their shocks using specialized electric organs.
And considering the paralyzing power the Tobi-Kadachi’s
zaps seem to have, I’d theorize that they
also have some form of internal electric organ...
With this scuffle over with, the Tobi-Kadachi
retreats higher up into the canopy.
With an impressive leap, they return to their
nest high in the branches, and stretch out
for the equivalent of an afternoon cat-nap.
Considering the power the Tobi-Kadachi possesses,
it’s best to continue on, and not disturb
their slumber…
At long last, I reach the highest point of
the forest.
Here, at the crown of the canopy, a curious
environment is waiting.
This large clearing is defined by charred
wood and piles of discarded bones.
It almost seems like a single, giant nest…
but for what?
From the sky comes the answer.
This is a Rathalos, a flying lifeform and
the true ruler of the Ancient Forest.
The Rathalos spend their days soaring over
their domain on vast wings, occasionally touching
down to feed upon the lifeforms below.
When a Rathalos feels challenged, they will
end disputes quickly with a powerful jet of
internally-produced flame.
And since any given Rathalos must maintain
a wide territory, they’ve evolved to be
quite aggressive towards intruders.
I think it would be wise for me to stay out
of sight.
Yet as the sun sets, I manage to observe another
side to these widely-feared creatures.
I watch this Rathalos preen their scales while
they sit atop their treetop throne, before
curling up and going to sleep for the night.
While a Rathalos could certainly spell my
doom while awake, this moment of stillness
helps demonstrate that many of these organisms
— while powerful — aren’t truly monstrous.
All the same, I find that I can breathe easier
once I’m back in the familiar glow of civilization.
The village of Astera is a welcome sight after
a long and risky expedition.
And despite the still-present smell of old
laundry, my accommodations have never seemed
better...
Elsewhere on the continent, there are more
fascinating regions to explore and more extreme
lifeforms, and I’ll likely set out on another
expedition soon.
Let me know if you liked this style of video
and want to see more.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, you can lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.